en juego está la forma en la que los
países occidentales
deberían aproximar a la estrategia de
beijing de incrementar su participación
militar y de seguridad en la región de
asia-pacífico
en segundo lugar están en juego la forma
en la que se distribuyen o proliferan
armas de destrucción masiva los
proyectos que sustentaban franjas por un
lado y eeuu por el otro eran muy
distintos los primeros eran submarinos
potenciados principalmente por dices y
los segundos por propulsión nuclear con
la capacidad de dotar de tecnología
nuclear a australia por parte de eeuu y
de el reino unido así mismo hay un
tercer elemento supremamente importante
y son las economías de escala que se
adquieren en la industria naval a partir
de estos mega contratos recordemos que
era un contrato de dinero de hoy de más
de 30 billones de dólares pero que la
tecnología en materia le asiste en
materia de
transferencia de tecnología llegaba a
ser hasta el próximos 30 años por lo
tanto era una empresa significativamente
importante para francia que percibe y
sigue percibiendo que los estados unidos
y reino vio se atravesaron en un negocio
que estaba prácticamente cerrado ahora
rafael el ministro de exteriores de
francia álamos de xian y adrián le dijo
a su homólogo estadounidense anthony
blinken que se necesitará tiempo y
también acciones para salir de esta
crisis y poder restablecer la confianza
entre ambas potencias a qué pasos cree
usted que se refiere y que debería
ocurrir para superar la crisis y las
tensiones
es un elemento de profunda atención
cuando hablamos de tiempo y espacio
estamos hablando de que hace poco más de
dos o tres meses el presidente joe biden
estuvo de gira en europa y les aseguro a
los países europeos que les consultaría
cuando se fueran a tomar decisiones
importantes
afganistán y el acuerdo que ya se venía
negociando desde varios meses atrás
demuestran lo contrario por lo tanto
otros temas de la agenda internacional
como el manejo de la pandemia como la
cumbre sobre medioambiente
a cabo la cop15 en octubre próximo y la
con 26 en glasgow se espera que te
lleguen a acuerdos concretos acuerdos de
los países desarrollados es decir eeuu
canadá a los países europeos para la
financiación de los planes del medio
ambiente yo creo que cuando hablamos de
acciones concretas hablamos de allí pero
hay otro elemento importante y es que no
nos desviemos del elemento central y es
la seguridad y la defensa el presidente
manuel mayor hace dos años mencionó que
la otan era un enfermo terminar en un
enfermo que se estaba muriendo y sin
duda alguna
eeuu ha sido un férreo defensor de su
presencia en europa a través de la otan
yo creo que lo que se esperaría por
parte del gobierno francés y de algunas
autoridades europeas es que eeuu deje de
poner trabas a la mayor autonomía en
seguridad y defensa por parte de los
países de europeos en general y de
francia en particular y al mismo tiempo
los países europeos van a seguir
presionando a eeuu para qué
transferencia tecnológica que es este
país hasta el recipiente a otorgarles en
otras palabras estamos hablando del
compromiso euroatlántico en términos de
seguridad de defensa que ha estado bajo
el paraguas de la toma mientras últimos
60 años pero que sin duda alguna los
intereses estratégicos de los países
europeos pueden ir significativamente
siendo divergentes a los estadounidenses
no sólo en el viejo continente sino a
nivel mundial lo cual muestra la crisis
por la que está pasando francia con sus
homólogos de eeuu reino unido y
australia sino que ya no queda muy poco
menos dos minutos unos 30 segundos
aproximadamente pero vinculado a las
últimas respuestas están aumentando las
flexiones y la desconfianza ante el rol
de eeuu qué consecuencias puede haber de
no a nivel global teniendo en cuenta
esto
si tenemos en cuenta el momento por el
cual estamos pasando el manejo de la
pandemia y el medio ambiente han sido
los temas reiterativos en la cambia
general de las naciones unidas que se
llevó a cabo en nueva york' y sin duda
alguna hacen parte de la agenda
euroatlántica otros temas como la
seguridad en europa especialmente
como contener a rusia podría ser otro
tema que se ha tenido en cuenta en la
agenda euroatlántica singh y que sin
duda alguna hay que estar atentos a cómo
evoluciona nada en los meses por venir
rafael dinero muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france24